we've got two out of our three
asynchronous requests working let's get
some Wikipedia articles about the page
to show up we're on the MediaWiki api
page because wikipedia is run by
MediaWiki and looking through this page
you'll actually find you don't need an
api key however making normal JSON
requests to Wikipedia would result in a
cross origin or a cross-site error
because Wikipedia servers forbid
cross-origin requests there are several
ways we can make this request to
Wikipedia one would be to set the origin
and content type headers on the request
and then Wikipedia would allow it or we
can just use JSON P in our example we'll
be using JSON P a JSON P request is a
somewhat convoluted trick that involves
a server wrapping the response inside a
function to get injected when it
actually gets back to the client
but luckily if this sounds confusing
don't worry jQuery actually makes it
pretty easy to make a JSON P request
will use the more robust dot Ajax method
in fact the get JSON method we were
using before was actually just an
abstraction of the dot Ajax method which
is incidentally also an abstraction of
an asynchronous JavaScript request for
this quiz use the dot Ajax method to
collect data from a Wikipedia endpoint
let's take a look at the structure of
the finished page we start off with a
Wikipedia container that has all the
links and then inside of it we have this
unsigned list with an ID of Wikipedia
links going through the unsigned list we
see just a couple list elements and then
within each list element we simply have
an a tag with a link to Wikipedia each a
tag of course contains the title of the
Wikipedia article within it and like you
did before for this quiz you'll need to
properly append each Wikipedia article
to the page you'll need to include a few
parameters inside your Ajax request
there will of course be a URL you'll
need to include a data type notice - in
the signature that we don't have an
optional success function parameter
instead you'll have to set it as a
property make sure your success
parameter is set to a function that you
want to run when the request is returned
successfully
to start off you will fire off a json p
request using dollar sign Ajax and then
into dollar sign HX you'll pass a
settings object that will include a
parameter for data type and a parameter
for success once you get the response
iterate through it and then present
articles on the page and they should end
up inside the unsigned list with the ID
of Wikipedia links when you're done
check this box